report exactly okay magnus has he
calculated this one correctly black does
take that pawn white's queen also
capturing suddenly whose king is weaker
i don't know i'm not sure if the players
know either
in armageddon chess blitz chess king
safety is
is everything it's paramount white's
queen however very active
magnus going for the kill now he's
pushing his pawn forward yeah well this
is a nice move by
wesley you know offering to trade queens
but 28
seconds to complete the rest of his
wesley's not going to make it
yeah i think he's going to lose on the
clock wesley if he doesn't lose on the
board
he still needs to save it on the board
especially after that last move white's
getting active
where's he's smiling he knows it's going
to be all over soon
20 seconds and magnus wins wow look at
that
magnus carlsen in armageddon
finally beats wesley so and look at that
reaction that is
huge wow david what do you take away
from that
i've never seen the world champion that
emotional
that's how much relief he feels